vous le verrez rarement se déplacer sans
son cortège de sécurité depuis qu'il
fait l'objet de menace de mort Alvin
brag est construit par la droite
américaine
on a fait son ennemi public numéro 1
tout sépare ces deux hommes à
l'exception peut-être de leurs origines
New Yorkaises
dans le Harlem de son enfance marquée
par la violence il raconte avoir eu une
arme à feu pointée sur lui assez
reprises dont trois fois par des
policiers il étudiant droit à la
prestigieuse université Harvard où il se
spécialise dans la défense des droits
civils
un système doit être réformé quand il y
a trop d'inégalités raciale dit-il
devant les membres de son église le
juriste d'allégeance démocrate brise le
poste de procureur général de Manhattan
sur la promesse inculter l'ancien
président Donald Trump
il devient le premier Afro-Américain a
occupé ce poste en janvier 2022
jours après son entrée en fonction on
demande déjà sa démission la fuite de
note interne révèle qu'il veut cesser
d'être tenter des poursuites pour des
délits qu'il juge mineur comme la
prostitution ou encore les entrées par
effraction face au télé il doit reculer
et en assume l'entière responsabilité
sera toutefois le fardeau des enquêtes
contre Donald Trump elles avancent trop
lentement aux yeux des procureurs qui
mènent le dossier ce qui les pousse à
démissionner mais sa patience est
récompensée à l'automne 2022 quand le
directeur financier de la crampe
organisation plaid coupable pour fraude
et évasion fiscale
c'est une conduite inacceptable à
Manhattan dit-il peu importe qui vous
êtes Alvin brag n'a pas dit son dernier
mot et portera d'autres chefs
d'accusation contre la Trump
organisation elle-même et contre l'ex
conseiller du président Steve Bannen
fort de son succès le procureur brags
s'attaque au dernier acte de son œuvre
on n'est culpa pour la première fois un
ancien président des États-Unis ici Jean
Philippe use Radio-Canada Montréal